time now for CBS morning's deals where
we share the items that might make your
day a little bit better a little
brighter all at exclusive discounts to
start shopping now scan the QR code on
your screen upper left there or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Elizabeth
Werner joins us now Elizabeth thank you
for being here oh my gosh thank you
we're going to begin with some items to
help Vlad start his summer early
apparently here that's right so we got
wow Sports brings us all of these great
items to play in the water during the
summer time we've got Vlad over there
hanging out on a lounger it's got the
little armrest this that I'm standing on
is an actual Sumo area where we put on
our Sumo bellies we can play Sumo and
this actually you connect a hose and
water sprinkles everywhere so it's wet
it's fun this is fun yes now eight game
on if you go to yeah if you go to
cbsdeals.com by the way you're going to
see a ton of great items from this
company sprinklers water slides so
definitely check it out Vlad is that
comfy or what loving it yeah yes all
right I'll lose my belly and we can move
over here all right so if you mess your
hair up yeah yeah
so starting off at
79.99 they're 31 off and go to
cbsdeals.com to see all of the variety
all right let's talk about fixing up
hair yes so Con Air it's been around
since 1959. my Mom's here today her
first hair dryer was the yellow Conair
hair dryer so we always talk about it
well this is the oh so kindset this is a
curling iron a curling wand and a
flattening iron well with these they all
are designed to be gentle on the hair
and not damage the hair so today I
straighten my hair it's normally a
little wavy a little curly I left a
piece here but they are designed with
this has nice ceramic plates in it so
it's smooth it's not going to damage
hair so great for aging hair thin hair
fine hair and regular hair because
they're all different temperatures that
you can set based on the type of hair
you have so think of all the other
products out there the prices are insane
they're in hundreds of dollars when they
have this many heat settings and
protections in them these are starting
at just 19.99 up to 40 percent off wow
that's Conair all right so it's
beginning to keep it a little bit warm
down by the water it gets cool yes all
right so I'm going to hand you this the
most relaxing soft delicious blankets do
you need one over there wow we'll throw
one over to Vlad
so this is Chula Tula these are soft
gorgeous beautiful blankets made by yes
they're made by artisans in South Africa
so this company works hard to hire
people in underserved communities they
have over 600 employees these are hand
done they work on a loom they are
literally heirloom quality One of a Kind
all of this is brushed by hand the
little tassels are done by hand so I
love that they're employing these
these amazing people in the actual
community and creating one-of-a-kind
blankets so this is not like what you
find elsewhere and by the way I
decorated in my family room with this
yes and you know people that have worn
this uh Nelson Mandela Prince Harry Pope
Francis it was even in the Black Panther
movie wow these have some real appeal to
everybody one-of-a-kind heirloom pieces
starting at just 62 how is it Vlad it
has a great price super warm yeah right
warm and soft okay golf yes all right so
girls this is clock it golf imagine
tetherball but now for golf so this goes
into the ground we just put it right
into the grass you screw it in like this
once it's in the ground you're going to
be working on your stroke on your
strength on your consistency but how
much fun is this you're having a party
you're having a barbecue you put this in
you bring your clubs out and then you're
able to actually have fun with all of
your friends taking turns hitting the
ball so you're going to learn how to hit
the ball in The Sweet Spot it's an
actual golf ball and they use nautical
rope so it's not going to break so
here's what's not going to happen you're
not going to lose your balls you don't
have to go after them you don't actually
have to go somewhere to actually golf
you can do it right in the backyard
what's the price on this one starting
yes 41.99 30 off wow Father's Day
Mother's Day a lot cheaper than the
driving range exactly thank you very
much and of course we do partner with
all these companies to get these deals
to buy anything you saw today scan the
QR code on your screen or head over
cbsdeals.com to start shopping right now
we will be right back Sumo time
[Music]